le fournil et les baguettes une
tradition familiale chez les perrichon
comme ses frères
michael est devenu boulanger par passion
l'usure et la routine de mots que
l'artisan sénonais ne connais pas ce qui
me plaît c'est dans le métier c'est la
transformation de la matière première en
produits finis et puis c'est jamais la
même chose c'est tous les jours déjà les
recettes change suivant le temps
suivant la matière première qu'on reçoit
c'est jamais une farine c'est une
matière première qui évolue donc sait
jamais on n'a jamais la routine quoi si
cette passion l'animent depuis 20 ans
michael le reconnaît au fil du temps le
métier de boulanger est devenu moins
attractif et il devient difficile de
former des apprentis les contraintes
on les connaît tous assez travail de
nuit travail les jours fériés travaillés
les dimanches après c'est les
contraintes ou et non quand on est
passionné
on les accepte mais ça oui ça restait
contre un métier en pleine mutation qui
s'explique également par un changement
des habitudes du côté des consommateurs
je pense qu'ils sont plus exigeants par
rapport à la qualité de nos produits
dans les années 80 c'était du pain blanc
avec un fort pétrissage des pins qui
avait pas beaucoup de boue est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus on arrive
avec des pins qui ont démis plus foncée
des pins plus travailler alors que les
français consomment aujourd'hui cinq
fois moins de pain qu'au début du 20e
siècle
les boulangers doivent désormais se
diversifier un choix qui comporte des
risques le risque d'élargir la gamme ces
deux
c'est plus de temps dans son fournil
c'est plus de main d'oeuvre c'est et
puis des pertes supplémentaires parce
que puis on va élargir sa gamme plus on
adhère le soir pour se démarquer de la
concurrence et éviter le gaspillage le
boulanger ces données a décidé de
limiter sa gamme
un choix qui lui permet de ne proposer
que des produits faits maison